很多人問我
得高血壓
就註定要吃藥一輩子嗎
如果一直
靠藥物強制降血壓
恐怕一輩子
會因副作用而痛苦
早上八點鐘
阿明攔了一輛計程車
一上車
司機大哥
我要到機場
我趕著搭飛機
麻煩你快一點
嗯 你要搭幾點的飛機啊
我趕八點半的飛機
哎呦喂呀
你不要開玩笑啦
我開到機場
最快也要半個小時
飛機早就飛走了
你來不及了啦
司機大哥
飛機應該還沒飛走
因為我就是
這班飛機的機長
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
很多人問我
得高血壓
就註定要吃藥一輩子嗎
如果一直
靠藥物強制降血壓
恐怕一輩子
會因副作用而痛苦
今天我會跟你分享
想治好高血壓
你要了解比吃藥
更重要的觀念
要找出真正的原因
我還會告訴你
能保住生命的良方喔
血壓高原因1 脖子僵硬
今天來講三種造成血壓高的原因
注意喔
現在許多上班族
或者是主管們久坐不動
肩膀就這樣盯著打電腦
下了班就覺得很累
回到家又窩在沙發上不想動
或者是低頭滑手機
這樣就會造成這個肩膀
頸子這個地方
僵硬使血液不容易流向頭部
於是造成頭暈頭痛頭脹耳鳴
或者是
頸部僵硬感
非常非常糟糕
那麼這樣子的話呢
血液不流通
也就是所謂的瘀血了
血液受阻了腦袋就會缺氧
因此必須用更大的力量
來把血液輸送到全身
血壓那當然就要高了對不對
手肘1處鬆肩頸 2穴降血壓
解決脖子肩膀僵硬的
一個穴位
這個穴位在哪個地方
其實很簡單
就是一個尺澤穴
這個尺澤穴
它雖然說是肺經的穴道
但是它可以舒緩
肺經的毛病
以及在背部的肺俞穴
它可以讓這邊的血液循環
背上面的這個肺俞穴
又能夠影響到血液的供應良好
脖子血液循環不良
就是這個地方的問題
你把這個尺澤穴按壓一下
你把每天這樣左右手各按一下
它怎麼做呢
是這樣子
手心向著天花板的時候
在手肘彎彎橫紋上
大拇指這條線上
就是這一個穴
你就這樣輕輕這樣各按個
三分鐘到五分鐘
一面按一面把脖子就這樣子
搖一搖動一動
自然的血液循環
就脖子的血液循環就變好了
自然的這個頸動脈
它的血液就流通到頭腦去了
因此頭腦裡頭的血液供應足夠
血壓自然就降下來了
我教你一招用敲的
這樣敲的時候
因為你在敲
你不是定點
而是有的時候敲到上面一點
有的時候敲的下面一點
結果呢
有時候就敲中了那個真正的穴位
因此就有這個效果
所以教給你用敲的方式
你就這樣敲一敲敲一敲
這樣敲
那除了這個穴位以外
還有兩個
可以增強你的血液循環的穴位
一個是足三里
一個是三陰交
這個在以前的
很多節目裡頭我都有提到過
足三里也是這樣敲一敲
三陰交也是這樣敲一敲
比起你這樣子直接按
說不定你按不準確對不對
這樣敲的話
就幾乎有機會碰對了
你知道嗎
敲多了保養身體
而且還能夠延年益壽
不過還要提醒一下
假如你是一個孕婦的話
三陰交你就別敲了
也別去按了好嗎
血壓高原因2 生氣緊張
生氣的時候你知道嗎
交感神經亢奮
周邊血管就收縮
這個時候
血液就沒有辦法把
氧氣直接送到全身各處
這個時候
他就有這種血壓高的這個狀況
我有一個病人
他大概年紀五十歲左右的一個太太
身體稍微有點胖
她跟我講
她的血壓總是在200左右這麼高
看了西醫怎麼降都降不下來
吃了好多的降血壓藥
降血壓只有六種
那她這六種都試過了
也都沒有降下來
結果她就來找我
我給她治療
治了一段時間之後你知道嗎
她血壓竟然降到了140 150
高興的不得了
到處跟人家說
胡醫師把我的血壓給治好了
當時我就告訴她說
你不要亂講
你的血壓高不是我治的
是你自己治的
因為什麼呢
因為你聽我的話
我叫你怎樣做你就怎樣做
然後我開了個藥
只不過這個藥呢
它的作用就是讓你的
精神不那麼緊張
當你的情緒很高張的時候
那麼交感神經亢奮了
交感神經一亢奮
最主要的就是
把你的心臟給改變了
心臟要不就是跳動很快
要不就是跳動很強力
這個時候
你量起來血壓就是很高
可是你想假如說
你的脾氣不那麼
容易發怒
然後每天都是快快樂樂的呀
你只要舒緩你自己情緒的話
那就好了
所以我給你開的藥
就是舒緩情緒的藥
然後你自己又配合了
讓你自己的情緒降低下來
所以你才會好的
這並不是我幫你治好了
菊花茶和它 心情好降血壓
我來講第一招
第一招就是
用茶飲讓你心情舒緩
你知道嗎
喝什麼樣的茶很好
菊花
就是一個菊花
你大概在一個馬克杯裡面
丟個差不多十朵左右的菊花
不管是黃菊花白菊花
或者野菊花
只要是菊花
丟幾顆菊花下去
然後用熱水沖泡
等到泡香了
就是那個菊花泡開來了
變成有一點香味了就可以喝
如果你很想讓它變的更好吃一點
你可以加一點甘草
或者是加一點枸杞這就好了
再跟你講一個茶
這個茶呢
是要煮一煮
才能夠煮出味道的
就叫做甘麥大棗湯
甘麥大棗湯
假如你把它當湯吃也可以
當茶吃也可以
所謂當湯就是煮的濃一點
所謂當茶那就是煮的稀一點
那我今天就讓你把它變成茶來喝
甘草大約四錢
小麥一兩
這小麥的最好是浮小麥
所謂浮小麥就是它比較輕的
所謂比較輕是什麼意思呢
就是那個小麥
已經放的時間
比較長一點了的那種小麥
到藥房買的時候
你就叫浮小麥
甘草四錢
小麥一兩
大棗大概十二顆
所謂大棗就是紅棗
你不要用黑棗
這個地方用紅棗就好了
用水1500cc
放到鍋子裡頭煮
煮成1000cc
然後當做一天的茶來喝
可以天天喝
你情緒愉快了
就不容易生氣
前面講那個太太
我也讓她喝了甘麥大棗湯
所以情緒就變的比較好一點
哦所以沒有喝之前
是不是這樣說
你再說一次我就要生氣囉
然後喝了之後就會說
你再這樣我就要生氣氣囉
血壓高原因3 天氣冷 1物升血壓
血壓之所以會升高
在我們用中醫的觀點來看
中醫看病呢
它是從外因
天氣
風火熱濕燥寒等等
哪一個原因造成了你的血壓高
從情緒上面問你
喜 怒 憂 思 悲 恐 驚
你到底犯了哪一項
那然後呢再來治這個血壓
好
我告訴你
我們用中醫的方式來分析血壓
冷了血壓會升高
好我們用西醫的講法呢
很簡單
冷了的時候周邊血管就收縮
為什麽會收縮呢
是因為交感神經亢奮
交感神經亢奮周邊血管一收縮
那結果血壓血液
都流到比較中間的地方
那這時你量血壓
當然是高了嘛對不對
好
量血壓高了
其實它是怎麼樣
冷了是保護你的身體的熱
不要從這個周邊排除出去
因此血液都留在中間
因此身體也會比較熱和一點
不但如此
血壓當然就會增高
那血壓增高了
可以使得這個血液呢
可以送到各個地方
那這樣子的話呢
自然的
血壓就
就是到了需要已經滿足了
血壓就自然的就降低了是不是
好
這個時候
冷就是造成血壓高的一個原因
那麼冷你要怎麼辦
很簡單
你穿一件衣服使身體保暖了
或者拿一個暖暖包
讓你的手腳這周邊溫暖了
自然這個血壓就不高了嘛
就這麼簡單的一個理
可是我們不是
我們常常都是
跑去吃降血壓的藥
這個時候你要知道
你可能就使得血壓降的太過
還容易造成所謂
腦血栓中風
或者其它的中風
痛了 緊張了 煩惱了
血壓也會增高
剛剛不是講嗎
外因冷
那內因呢
可能緊張
可能煩惱
這些都可能造成
還有疼痛這些都可能
好
疼痛 緊張 煩惱
交感神經也會亢奮
這個時候周邊血管也是收縮
這一收縮了
心跳就加快
血壓升高
而且
真正的原因疼痛而是減輕了
或者是那個緊張沒有了
或者那個煩惱沒有了
我告訴你自然血壓也就降低了
所以你要感謝你的血壓會高
就是讓你能夠立刻的反應
那些不好的狀況而改善它
一直吃藥 恐造成永久性血壓高
我想跟你說一個事情
如果只是利用藥物來強制
降低血壓
會有頭暈
頭痛
噁心
心跳變慢
或者是心悸
等等的副作用
降血壓的藥劑
通常就是
那麼幾種
例如利尿劑
血管擴張劑等等
它的目的呢就是強制
讓身體的血壓降下來
它們的副作用有哪些呢
會造成
腎臟負擔
還可能讓心肌變厚
我告訴你
因為血壓太低了
心臟它覺得它沒有辦法
把血液送到各處去
因此心肌啊
就要用大力量
越做越工作的強
它越工作的勤奮
那個時候心肌
就開始變厚
心肌變厚就可能造成
永久性的血壓高
有高血壓的狀況呢
還是要經過
審慎的檢驗
不要輕易判定
就是高血壓病
因此呢
就要吃降血壓藥
你可別吃了冤枉藥
又沒把身體治好
正在吃
降血壓藥的朋友
看完這一集
好好思考
或找到你的醫生
來好好的跟他討論
如何讓你的身體
更好的方式
3種天然好物 護心降血壓
血壓高的朋友
除了藥物
還可以透過飲食
來穩定血壓
介紹你三種天然的食物
一芹菜
二堅果
三香蕉
芹菜裡頭
有一種成份
叫做芹菜鹼
可以保護心血管
堅果能幫助
穩定血壓
每天吃幾顆
例如說
一小把呀
就可以了
也不要吃的過量
香蕉呢
有豐富的鉀
能夠維持心跳的穩定
防止高血壓和中風
香蕉一天最多吃兩根
如果你是腎功能不全
或腎衰竭的人
這個時候
也會血壓高對不對
那這種人
不要吃香蕉
還是問一問
你的醫生再說吧
一個訊息
從地球這一端
到另一端
只需要幾秒
而一個觀念
從頭腦之外
進入頭腦裡面
有的時候
需要一段時間才會改變
看完這一集
對高血壓
有更清楚的認識
別只聽到
高血壓就以為
非得要吃藥
而且還不能停藥
其實應該要找到
對的方式改善生活
喜歡這支影片的朋友
歡迎按影片下方的「超級感謝」
給我們支持喔